[Music]
[Music]
it is
seven o'clock in the uk good to see you
this morning a taste of things to come
as a review of what we should be eating
is served up we'll be taking a look at
what's on the menu to reduce our
wastelands
and cut carbon emissions plus why the
prime minister
is keen to make sure that no one loses
out as part of his
so-called leveling up agenda for the uk
we'll be asking the housing secretary
robert generic about that
in just a few minutes time
[Applause]
a remarkable this who dares wins 15 year
old sal hussein
will be telling us what it's like being
the youngest person
to complete the sas endurance trial
carrying a 35 pound
pound pack on his back also this morning
[Music]
we'll be speaking to the award-winning
singer-songwriter tom adele who's used
the experience of his
mental health problems to create his
latest album it is
thursday 15th of july
not robbing peter to pay paul boris
johnson to argue that his leveling up
agenda is a
win-win for everyone as he sets out his
post-pandemic vision for the uk
breaking news this morning reports as
many as 30 people are missing
after several houses collapsed during
heavy rain and flooding
in western germany we'll have the latest
snack attack calls for attacks on sugar
and salt
with food and veg prescribed on the nhs
as part of a national food strategy for
england
we are producing salt we have reduced
sugar but there's only so far you can go
until someone says that's land
winter warning scientists claim as many
as 60
000 people could die from flu as a
combination
of seasonal viruses and covered 19 could
overwhelm the nhs
toxic claims britney spears breaks down
in tears
and tells an la court she wants her
father charged with conservatorship
abuse
going for a song and music streaming
means musicians and songwriters are
receiving
meager returns for their work
mainly dry sunny and warm the summer
weather
is finally here but how long will it
last for i'll have the answer for you
later
morning all right boris johnson will
today set out his post pandemic plan to
level up the uk
in a speech later today the prime
minister will stress his flagship
program will benefit the whole country
but some of his mps are nervous they
fear seats in the conservative southern
heartlands could be starved of funds
to boast of their new parliamentary
constituencies in the north and the
midlands
our political correspondent joe pike
reports now from birmingham
we're going to level up my government
will level up we are serious
about wanting to level up it's
supposedly the central project of boris
johnson's premiership
but could investment in newly
conservative constituencies in the north
come at the expense of the party's
heartlands in the south
just last month the tories lost the
previously true blue seat of cheshire
and amisham to the lib dems today the
prime minister will try to allay
some of those concerns he's expected to
say
we don't want to decapitate the tall
poppies we don't think you can make the
poor parts of the country richer
by making the rich parts poorer leveling
up is not a jam
spreading operation it's not robbing
peter to pay paul
it's not zero sum it's win-win
part of that plan is about regenerating
high streets and improving businesses
like this one in birmingham
its outdoor space has tripled in size
since rules were temporarily relaxed
during the pandemic
boris johnson wants to make that
permanent
wow i mean that would be wonderful
being able to have the extended area
outside permanently
it means a lot to me in terms of the
business but also personally because
it's very important for me to improve
the street scene and
create nice dining experience for people
outside and
all year round i think it's what people
want making
outdoor dining like this permanent seems
a popular idea but if boris johnson
really wants to change the country
it'll cost he's already spent hundreds
of billions of pounds on the
government's response
to kovid and if the prime minister
really wants to level up
he'll need to explain how he'll pay for
it what i really hope we don't see
is that having spent 10 years basically
trashing the economy trashing poorer
places
flat wages the government just throws a
few quid on the table
and says here you go that's now leveling
up that's what you might call bullingdon
club economics where you smash up the
restaurant
throw a few tenants on the table and ask
the staff to just
make do we don't need bullying and club
economics we need a proper
strategy to create equal rights and fair
chances in this country
today's speech is just the vision we'll
have to wait until the autumn
for the detail joe pike sky news
birmingham
and i am reliably informed that
technical issues have been put to one
side and we do indeed have the housing
secretary robert genwick joining us on
the programme once again very good
morning to you mr general
good morning we have of course heard an
awful lot about about levelling up it
has been one of boris johnson's mantra
since he became prime minister just tell
us a little about what we will be
hearing from the pm later today
well the pm's going to be making a
speech in the west midlands which
reaffirms
our commitment to leveling up all parts
of the country
one of the absolutely central tenets of
our manifesto back in 2019 before the
pandemic
and which feels even more important than
ever now as we're moving into
a different period of living with the
virus and recovering
our economy and he's going to say that
we want to ensure that all parts of the
country
benefit from this agenda it's not about
the north versus the south
it's not about taking down poor the
richer areas in order to
to build up the poorer ones is to
everyone's benefit this is a national
win-win and we're going to do this by
investing
in skills in transport in culture
and ensuring there's more pride in
places like high streets
and town centres and we also want to
give more power
back to local communities because we are
one of the most centralized
countries in the world and so we're
going to be supporting local mayors like
andy street
here in the west midlands where i am
this morning and local councils and
communities
so that they can take greater charge of
their own destiny
as we build that better as you say this
was a manifesto commitment back in 2019
the prime minister
needing today to reaffirm it i'm just
wondering if anything has actually been
done
on the leveling up agenda since it was
announced
yes it has we've actually made a huge
amount of progress despite the pandemic
in my own department we've been working
in 30
of the towns of england ensuring over 10
billion pounds the largest ever
injection of investment in regeneration
took place and where i am in
wolverhampton today
is one of the recipients of that to give
you an example of leveling up in action
we're investing 40 million pounds in the
high street
and town center here in wolverhampton so
that the city can
move forwards we're also working with
andy street on the tram
so that people can get into birmingham
can access hs2 when that arrives
to get better connectivity to high
paying jobs
and later today i'm going to be looking
at my own government department which is
moving to wolverhampton so that a young
person growing up here
can access just the same opportunities
as somebody growing up in london who
might want to work
for government that feels to me is
exactly what leveling up
is all about well the white paper will
be published in the ottoman we all await
it with baited breath and but of course
we're about four days
from what some previously called freedom
day i
i just wondered with the the guidance
that emerged to hospitality and retail
last night
essentially being the same as it has
always been face masks still expected to
be worn in shops table service should
remain
in bars and restaurants customers i
should be checking in when they they
enter these premises i'm
i'm just wondering whether we can
justify telling businesses to carry on
in the way in which they have done
having
labeled this day freedom day
what we are saying is that although
we're in an immeasurably better position
thanks to the vaccine program
we're still very much living with the
virus we're going to be for a long time
and so we do need to exercise
caution the vaccine programs enable us
to move into a different
phase where it's not going to be a
matter of law
that these restrictions and uh
inhibitions remain in place but it will
be a matter of personal responsibility
and so we're asking every member of the
public to
be cautious to come to sensible
judgments about for example the wearing
of masks in close contact in indoor
spaces
and for businesses as well to consider
whether they want to and need to apply
those
restrictions and you can already see
that organizations such as
tfl which manages the tube in london
have come
to in my opinion a perfectly sensible
judgment that
in the close confines of the tube you
should be using a mask
and there's also some supermarkets that
are coming to that conclusion as well
there are others though however in the
sector
sure there are others however in the
sector that are suggesting that it's
just
another confused mess i mean hugh osmond
founder of the restaurant group various
eateries
what was billed as freedom day is
actually going to be chaos day
i can't see how anyone is supposed to
know what to do it's wednesday and i
can't tell you what we're going to do on
monday
uh roger barker policy director at the
institute of directors
whilst it is right that companies should
be allowed to make their own decisions
based on their unique circumstances it
is vital that government provide
businesses
with best practice in developing their
own policies i mean all of this is just
simply passing the buck you talk about
personal responsibility
you're essentially handing all the
responsibility over to the the business
leaders
the business community and they don't
know what to do
well i disagree with that we have
provided we disagree with you osmond and
roger barker you've just quite
with respect i disagree with them we've
published guidance today which you've
been
quoting and the guidance reflects a huge
diversity of businesses
across the country if you're a business
that's operating
uh in a space where there's lots of room
it's very unlikely that people are
coming into close
contact then they'll come to a different
judgment to for example
waterstones who i understand have
announced that they
will be asking their customers to wear
masks and
you know some of their stores are quite
small people might be lingering
whilst they're reading books and that
seems again a logical
decision and so we trust businesses just
as we trust members of the public
to come to them i'm not sure that the
business community would agree
i'm not sure the business community
would agree that you trust them and not
a mention
of vaccine passports past the prime
minister's lips when he announced all of
this on monday
we're now hearing that covered passports
could be used to get into bars and
restaurants
well no once again we're saying that
there will be some situations where
businesses
might choose to pursue these policies
using their best judgment and
in my experience having talked to
literally hundreds of businesses
over the course of the last year this is
the sort of discretion
that they want reflecting the fact that
businesses are often in very different
situations
and a one-size-fits-all approach backed
by the force of the law
isn't sensible when we're moving into a
period now where
in all likelihood we're going to be
living with the virus for a long time
and we need to take a different approach
that's what we're doing and personally
i think that there's every reason to
believe that members of the public
and businesses and operators of
transport systems for example
like the tram uh here in the west
midlands that those organizations
will come to sensible conclusions i
think but the evidence i've seen so far
from the businesses that have announced
their intentions they do seem to be
coming to logical
decisions or what they intend to do at
least initially then no doubt they'll
keep it under review as the environment
just
progresses part two of the uh
dimbleby food strategy released today uh
and an awful lot of talk around
sugar and salt taxes i mean first and
foremost is that something that the
government is considering
and secondly i just wanted to find out
your views on potentially sitting down
to a plate full of cultured meat which
is another one of the interesting
proposals
being outlined today well this is an
independent
review it was commissioned by government
a couple of years ago
uh but we haven't had any control over
uh the findings that
uh richard dimbleby has come to um
they're they're henry dembele so they're
interesting uh findings
the the environment secretary is going
to consider them and then bring forward
our own food strategy in the coming
months so i'm not going to comment on
the individual
proposals it does raise a very
significant issue for the whole country
clearly
our relationship with food and farming
is really important
on a whole range of different levels
from backing those businesses here in
the uk
instilling a sense of pride in us
supporting
local food obviously health and health
inequalities which are even more
prominent
as we come out of the pandemic and our
role internationally in striking trade
deals
and ensuring that we uphold high
standards for our food supply so there's
a lot of very important issues
that are raised by this report but we're
going to consider them carefully
and then set out our own proposals in
the coming months
mr jenning always good to have you on
the program thanks for being with us
at some breaking news now the latest
unemployment figures for the three
months
leading up to me have just come out our
man in the know
our business correspondent paul kelso
paul
let us know what do we know
uh the headline unemployment rate for
the quarter to mariner was 4.8
and that is a fall in the number of
people unemployed a modest one a 0.2
percent
fall in unemployment but continues the
recovery
in the labor market that we've seen
since the economy began to unlock since
the restrictions you've just been
discussing
began to be eased now unemployment is
still
almost one full percentage point higher
than it was pre-pandemic but the office
for national statistics
uh who've released these figures this
morning so it does show this continued
recovery in the labor market the number
of payroll
employees gives us an idea of how
quickly it is recovering 365 000
more people on payrolls that implies
full-time work in the quarter than in
the previous quarter
again still 200 000 fewer than
pre-pandemic but
showing signs of that recovery uh jobs
amongst uh for men appear to be
recovering faster than amongst women
still subdued the labour market for
women of course
we know many of the roles in the sector
of the economy
worst affected by covert and lockdown
were filled uh
by women there's also signs of young
people coming back into working and the
young
the most affected the uh 16 to 24
bracket those
most likely to have lost their jobs or
two have been furloughed
during covid there's another uh
interesting figure in here almost
10 percent more vacancies that is jobs
available jobs
needing to be filled uh now than they
were
pre-covered as you might expect that
pre-covered the labor market was
uh has not been hit by this huge shock
but it does give us this out of this
slight anomaly we have
people who are more people unemployed
but employers out there with lots of
vacancies
to fill so this is sign of this huge
shock that hit the labour market that is
still
being worked through as we emerge from
lockdowns
bolt many thanks indeed still to come on
the program
uh just after half past i'll be finding
out how the covert pandemic has led
to millions of children missing out on
vaccinations for
other diseases
at 20 to 8 i'll be speaking to minette
batters of the national farmers union
about the call for people to eat
far less meat in future to help protect
us and
our environment
i will also be discussing covered
injuries with professor callum semple
who's urging young people to get
vaccinated to protect their lungs
against covet scarring and we'll be
discussing that at five past
eight
but you might have had been mentioned to
robert jones just a couple of minutes
ago
a new salt and sugar tax is among
drastic changes
needed to encourage us to change the
food we eat and the way it's produced
because of the damage it's doing to us
as individuals and to the planet
according to food entrepreneur henry
dimbleby who set out a new report
on our food strategy and says we're
eating too much
junk food and too much meat well the
report finds
the poor diet contributes to an
estimated 60
000 deaths a year in england and cost
the economy
an estimated 74 billion pounds
it warns that the food we eat accounts
for around a quarter of greenhouse gas
emissions and is the leading cause of
biodiversity destruction
it therefore calls for the introduction
of a landmark sugar and salt tax
with some of the money raised used to
expand free school meals
and support healthier diets and people
living in the most deprived communities
the report also calls for food education
to become a central part of the national
curriculum
and it wants food standards to be
protected in new trade deals
as jared tubb reports
the amount of sugar and salt we eat in
the food we buy
is making us ill and has to be
drastically reduced
that is one of the findings from the
national food
strategy review which calls for new salt
and sugar taxes to persuade businesses
to
change their recipes some think it won't
work
we've looked at everything we do you
know we have reduced salt we have
reduced sugar
but there's only so far you can go until
someone says that's bland
so what do they do excuse me can we have
the salt can we have the [ __ ] yeah and
they just put it on themselves
the report says the tax could add a
penny to a packet of crisps
seven and a half pence to a small bar of
chocolate
it also says we have to cut the meat we
eat
by 30 percent over 10 years and use more
farmland to improve the environment this
report
pulls no punches it starts by saying the
food we eat
and the way we produce it is doing
terrible damage to our planet
to improve the nation's health it says
low-income families need
more help with a million extra free
school meals a day
and free fresh fruit and vegetables on
prescription
although at this food bank the idea got
a mixed response
i don't really eat fresh fruit and
vegetarian why not
it's just something i'm not used to it'd
do me good because i just found out i've
diabetes i said i've got a lot of fruit
this is called ascophilum the dosa and
the government is being told
alternative sources of food need to be
developed
this marine biologist makes ingredients
from seaweed and says
change can come fast this is already
being done
you know we're doing this at scale but
the point is that especially around the
uk this huge
opportunity to really advance that scale
in a sustainable way
so it's step changes but we can scale up
very very quickly
[Applause]
this review was commissioned by the
government for england
the devolved nations will develop their
own food
strategies but these findings are likely
to be influential
gerard sky news stokesley
[Music]
oh well at quarter to nine the man who
drew up that
national food strategy henry dimbleby
will be on the program
talking talking about tackling our love
of meat and
junk food scientists say as many as 60
000 people could die from flu this
winter as a lethal mix of seasonal virus
combined with corvid 19
could could leave the nhs unable to cope
uh let's see much more from our health
correspondent ashish joshi about this
morning ashish i i put in the
conditional there but people will be
worried
looking at that figure of potentially as
many as 60 000 deaths
yeah let's put this in some context neil
obviously 60 000 is an alarmist figure
and that i think has to be couched in
very specific terms now this
is a figure at the high end of the scale
the top end of the scale
if there are no interventions in place
this is a report commissioned by
sir patrick valance he wanted to look at
so the the pressures
that would be facing the nhs as it
approached winter this winter is very
different to the last and and there's
specific reasons for that last year
there were interventions in place it was
social distancing
and the society was pretty much shut
down so that meant that
the seasonal respiratory illnesses that
we have every winter
the flu season which claims between 10
and 30 000
lives that didn't happen people were
dying instead
of covid19 this winter we're likely to
have
these seasonal respiratory illnesses
roaring back
and there will be less resistance less
natural immunity to the seasonal viruses
will also have covet in our populations
and then you have
the additional pressures on the nhs that
the the things we see
every winter the shortage in bed
capacity staff
numbers um reduce significantly so all
of these
could if they're not tackled in advance
of this winter
have a devastating impact that was the
warning and remember this is the 60 000
at the very top end
of this prediction what the scientists
say
we must do to protect the nhs to stop it
becoming overwhelmed
is to have a an autumn booster
vaccine program and also a way of
identifying
who has flu and who has coveted 19. so
this could be
a simple test carried out in gp
surgeries or in clinics and and
this is a warning that action must be
taken now to prevent this sort of
pressure on the
the nhs come the winter ashish thank you
some of the days other news now and the
number of soldiers deployed
on the streets of south africa has
doubled to 5 000.
as the army and police struggle to quell
days of looting and violence in durban
and johannesburg a president sir
ramaphosa is considering boosting troop
numbers further at least
72 people have died in the worst unrest
in the country for years
brazil's president jarrah bolsonaro has
been admitted to hospital
after suffering from hiccups for 10 days
in a row
he tooted a picture of himself in his
hospital bed a few days ago he said
he has the condition 24 hours a day it's
thought he may need emergency surgery
a complete reset of the music streaming
model is needed
in order to properly reward musicians
that's according to mps on the digital
culture media and
sport committee his report on the
economics of streaming on sites like
spotify
apple music and youtube music warns that
the current system
only provides pitiful returns for
singers and songwriters
the report's recommendations include the
introduction of measures
allowing music creators to recapture the
rights to their work from labels
after a period of time
artists can earn less than 0.1 pence in
the pound
for every stream that they sell and that
some in a year
can make a couple of hundred pounds now
the live music
trade was sort of papering over the crux
of that but during the pandemic they've
not been
able to do that so now we're finding
that many music
musicians are really struggling and
therefore
we have looked at the industry itself
and what we found
is that there are pitiful returns and
that basically
the big companies are making huge money
but artists
and those frankly music lovers who love
the music produced by those artists
are losing out
the world's rarest stamp is returning to
britain permanently for the first time
in 140 years by armoured truck
the 1856 british guyana one
cent magenta stamp was bought for 6.2
million last month
it's been protected by intense security
including being kept
in a zero oxygen frame
britney spears has told a court in los
angeles she wants her father charged
with
conservatorship abuse in an emotional
hearing she listed a series of
grievances
including being denied vitamins and
coffee telling the court that that's not
abuse that's
just cruelty greg marlon reports now
from l.a
for those who march in support of her
there is a sense that
victory's coming for britney spears that
the campaign to free her from the legal
arrangement she says
has controlled her life for 13 years is
paying off
[Applause]
[Music]
after a lifetime in the spotlight it's
now in a courtroom she's making herself
heard
for the second time in three weeks this
time winning the right to pick her own
lawyer
to try to end the conservatorship once
and for all
it was another impassioned address to
the court by britney spears laying bare
what she described as the cruelty
of some of the conditions this
conservatorship imposes on her
and after 13 years demanding once again
that it should end
[Applause]
she accused her father jamie spears of
ruining her life as conservator
and abusing the process his lawyer said
such allegations
were unsubstantiated she celebrated the
court's decision
by posting this video of her horse
riding and turning cartwheels
she thanked her fans you have no idea
what it means to me she wrote
signing off with the hashtag free
brittany
those fans are delighted we've been
laughed at
we've been called conspiracy theorists
but you know to hear britney herself
confirm
you know these things that we've been
fighting for for her it is a little
validating but again i can't
fully celebrate until she's completely
free for many of those listening into
reports from inside court this is also
about
others subject to conservatorships
imagine all of the people who don't have
anybody to speak up for them who are
having their money taken their bodily
autonomy they don't have freedom
this is america i mean it's almost it's
unbelievable that it's still happening
to anybody so it's kind of disturbing to
consider
that it's taken all of this just for one
little thing to change since 2008
for somebody who's so famous
it may yet take some time but it does
now seem inevitable
that britney spears will get the freedom
she
and her fans so desire greg milam sky
news los
angeles
[Applause]
30 people are reported to be missing
following the collapse of houses
during heavy rain in the town of schultz
in western germany
uh let's speak to our reporter uh who is
more on this
morning it is perhaps a a testament to
the strength of these floods that as yet
we haven't been able to get in there and
secure some pictures like just just tell
us what we know
morning so we do know these are once in
a generation floods that have hit
parts of western germany so far
reports are saying that four people have
died and 30 people are also missing it's
not known whether that
set of four people who have
unfortunately lost their lives
are part of the further 30 missing but
the german weather service has put in
place
an extreme weather warning for free
further parts of the western
region of the country and the reports
are startling
we have heard that the that firefighters
have drowned
that the army has needed to be deployed
to help in the relief
effort and the nearby city of hagen
which has
a population of around 180 000 people
there's a weather warning in place there
because the river has burst its banks
and
what officials are saying there is that
those are floods of
for the floods of the magnitude that you
only see four
times in a century people are being
asked to evacuate anyone who lives on
lower ground has been asked to move
from the city so the uh the the pictures
that we've not been able to receive so
far
uh sound startling and the situation
will get worse
many thanks indeed uh well let's reflect
on that and indeed
the weather situation here in the uk uh
nazis standing by
well nice of course we had we had some
pretty significant flooding in parts of
london just
just the other day is it the same
weather pattern that's
affecting germany yes well across
central parts of europe at the moment
there's a deep thundery low and that
is what is bringing those extremely
intense rainfalls across
parts of germany and many central parts
of europe not just for germany
and it's a lot of rain in a short space
of time well over a month's worth of
rainfall falling
in just a few hours hence the fact that
there was a flooding issues
the same two happened across western
parts of london
so it is remaining wet across many parts
of central europe as well
that thundery low is still going to be
sticking around there for the next
couple of days too
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning well it looks like the
summer weather has finally arrived
across many parts of the uk and ireland
for the rest of this week
there will be plenty of sunshine dry
weather and warmth as well in fact it
will be
locally becoming rather hot particularly
across parts of the south where
we are likely to see temperatures reach
up to 30 to 31 degrees celsius
on sunday that will be the first time
this year and in fact since september
last year
that we've seen temperatures rise above
30 degrees celsius it's quite
unusual for it to be this late in the
season
this morning it's tomorrow morning it's
bright for many areas but northern and
western parts quite cloudy with some
drizzle
especially for the northwest of scotland
northern and western parts of england
well some central areas also quite
cloudy but brighting up with lots of
sunshine this afternoon but
it may take some time for it to brighten
up for ireland and northern ireland
north west scotland stays quite cloudy
with some drizzle and then later
cloud amounts increase with cold
conditions across the east anglia and
the southeast
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come the
vaccination
fallout after the break we'll be hearing
how the covert pandemic has led to
millions of children
missing out on vaccinations for other
diseases
[Music]
welcome back the government has been
accused of putting out
confusing messages about whether people
should or shouldn't wear a mask when
england emerges from lockdown
many businesses including some shops say
they will be asking people to wear them
even though it won't be mandatory across
the country a little earlier in the
program the housing secretary robert
jenner told me it was down to personal
responsibility
and that different businesses will
exercise different rules
if you're a business that's operating uh
in a space where there's
lots of room it's very unlikely that
people are coming into close
contact then they'll come to a different
judgment to for example
waterstones who i understand have
announced that they
will be asking their customers to wear
masks and
you know some of their stores are quite
small people might be lingering
whilst they're reading books and that
seems again a logical
decision and so we trust businesses just
as we trust members of the public
to come to sensible reasonable decisions
uh let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen morning tc
um
trusting the public trusting businesses
to get it right however there are
some business leaders suggesting that
they could have a little bit of a hand
in working out exactly what best
practices
this is right the guidance to businesses
was published by the government last
night and
after being told a freedom day throwing
off all restrictions suddenly we're
being told that masks are recommended
visors are recommended checking in with
your phone when you get to a bar
or restaurant having table service all
that should continue in order
to prevent the transmission of the virus
which as robert generic was saying is
going to be with us
for some time now he was saying this is
what businesses want they want
discretion
but of course if you're a pub saying you
have to wear your mask when walking
around
you have to check in on your phone and
there's another pub down the road that
isn't doing that
you can see where the problems start and
that's why groups representing business
leaders like the institute of directors
are saying
this is confusing we want the government
to actually set out what
they want us to do rather than just
giving this strong guidance
and of course this is going to be the
problem for ministers going forward how
they enforce it if people say it's so
confusing we do different things
in different situations tomorrow for now
thanks very much indeed
now new data shows that the lives of
millions of children
needing protective vaccines have been
put at risk by the global covert
pandemic
children are in danger of catching
measles diphtheria whooping cough
and other illnesses because vaccination
programs have
dropped off drastically we're joined now
on the programme
by kate causey from the university of
washington's school of medicine she was
one of those
one of the lead authors on the study
kate really good to see you this morning
thank you for having me no no our
pleasure our pleasure just just give us
an idea
of how many children may have missed
vaccinations and
where those vaccination programs are
being missed
yes so we published results today
looking at the third dose of diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis
and the first dose of measles containing
vaccines around the world
and those estimates suggest that an
additional nearly nine million children
miss doses of each of those vaccines
across the globe
it is remarkable when you think about
the progress that we have made over the
past century in getting
global vaccination programs up and
running
i mean what are the health dangers in
all of this
well with each of these vaccines we're
likely to see
um outbreaks of vaccine preventable
diseases as you mentioned
diphtheria whooping cough measles um
especially as vaccination coverage rates
dipped below
expected levels and below target levels
is this going to have a knock-on effect
on the adult population or is it simply
a question of getting as much resource
together to to ensure that the children
who have missed out you know get
vaccinated
as soon as possible
um well it's hard to know i think that
we have learned if we've learned
anything this year
we've learned that our health around the
globe is
connected to each other and so making a
concerted effort to make sure we
are prioritizing routine immunization
programs
and providing targeted outreach to
children who have missed doses of these
important vaccines
will be essential for protecting the
health of children and all of us
we know of course when it comes to the
covert 19 vaccination program you know
countries in africa particularly in
sub-saharan africa have been
hardest hit i mean is it a similar
situation in terms of
the vaccinations that have been missed
dip theory of whooping cough and so on
well actually in this analysis we found
that the most
acute 2020 disruptions occurred in
north africa and the middle east south
asia and latin america and the caribbean
whereas in sub-saharan africa we saw the
smallest disruptions in 2020
and this may be due to the relatively
smaller scale of the epidemic
in that region particularly in the
earlier months of 2020
but it's also important to note that
this region had the lowest pre-pandemic
vaccine coverage levels around only 70
percent
so any additional children missing doses
in this region
is very concerning for child health yeah
it it certainly is i'm
kate causey from the university of
washington school of medicine thank you
so much for being with us and staying up
so late
thanks for having me now the food
entrepreneur henry dimbleby has set out
a new report
on our food and says we're eating too
much meat
and not enough veg he's calling for
sustainable farming techniques
and an equal division between intensive
farming and
environmentally friendly farming someone
with a view on all of this i'm sure
the president of the national farmers
union minette batters
joins us on the programme minette great
to see you this morning so
what do you make of it
well i've been part of henry jimboby's
advisory board
and i think actually what what he is
setting out is a new paradigm on food
and and for me
representing 50 000 farmers this is
about getting back to cooking from
scratch it's about whole foods
meat is a vital part of a healthy
balanced diet something where we
really need the macro and the
micronutrients and the good that it puts
back
into the soil so it is about a knee
paradigm on food i think we need to get
back to a more localized food system a
more added value
food system um we need to be refocusing
on procurement in our hospitals our
schools
buying british making sure that that we
really are
supporting farmers here but you know
we've seen on the back of covet how
people are buying everything out of
retail british sales are growing
and they are cooking from scratch and
things are really now i believe changing
we need to build on that
but just in terms of the the requirement
that he puts on all of us and it is it's
a
responsibility shared by everyone who
who eats meat that we all need to eat
rather less of it that can't come as
music to the ears of those who are
involved in the domestic production
of the meat that we eat
i i think farmers find this point
absolutely infuriating because actually
you know what what he is mainly talking
about is highly highly processed
food um not about people cooking from
scratch where they might go and buy some
mints by
steaks by a chicken breast you know he
is not talking about that yes
each and every one of us needs to eat
more vegetables
um you know i've always made the point
that you know farming here what we are
not consuming we should be able to
export to other countries
that don't have the luxury of a
grass-based system you know we have a
great climate here for growing grass for
feeding
livestock it's very different to other
parts of the world we have massive
feedlot systems don't forget we're
signing trade deals whereby we will have
no control
of how much is coming in here the
different standards that it is produced
to and ultimately this is about
consumer choice and inspiring consumers
to make the right choices to cook from
scratch to use
whole foods whole ingredients rather
than what henry is describing is a very
very highly processed
uh food that is bad for our diet so
we've got to inspire people this
food brings people together food is a
way of of healing
um you know the challenges that we have
but it's about
education um and it's about a culture as
much as anything else i think you don't
want to hit people in the wallet
that has no impact on their waistline
let's you know let's have this new
conversation about food and let's get
people
buying um and cooking from scratch and
buying whole foods yeah
you're speaking to me you're speaking to
a scotsman you don't you don't have to
convince me of the benefits of scottish
beef i have to tell you
minette really good to see you this
morning and thanks for being with us bye
now still to come on the program people
in wales will be getting more freedom
from this weekend but will still be
required
to wear masks and crowded spaces we'll
be talking at the economy minister for
wales von gething after the break
[Music]
well i mean i've always been interested
in flying and well really what uh
got me interested into this uh aviation
was uh
well uh interested in flying around the
world was uh when i started my uh
uh around the world when i started
thinking about this i
was running in gliders i started uh
flying in gliders
um when i was 12 and i went solo guide
on my 14th birthday and
i read a magazine article about someone
called lachlan smart who
broke the world record back in 2014 and
i just thought i really want to do that
and uh i thought you know if i
want to you know show and i want to
motivate young people uh
you know no matter what happens and what
challenges get in the way as long as you
keep
pushing towards your goals that's how
you can go and uh achieve them
so uh it's a cessna 172 aircraft
built in 2001 um it's my office my home
my uh yeah everything pretty much
and this is where i sit all the time
um and yeah quite quite a small aircraft
um but
uh you know enough for what i need and
i'll just show you
with all the uh all the lights on
turning the battery master and the uh
avionics master on and uh this is
essentially how i control the aircraft
with these
uh yolks here i've had some absolutely
amazing trips uh flying over the grand
canyon was
absolutely incredible and uh another
well uh the site's actually amazing as
well as that
flying down the hudson river in new york
over the statue of liberty really low
and actually flying down down the river
and the the skyscrapers in in new york
actually
above like how high i was so i was
flying quite low
and uh but i've had definitely some
scary moments uh had to deal with some
uh pretty bad icing and you know bad
weight wins
had a scary moment over the rockies in
montana and i actually dropped
about 2000 feet in about 30 seconds and
uh
it was a bit scary but i got out of it
fine and
other than that the trip's been
absolutely amazing my mum
and my both my parents had uh you know
some sleepless nights over
over me uh you know doing this trip but
uh yeah i think they're very happy i'm
back and uh well i think they're glad
they let me they let me go
i'm i'm not too sure actually what
what's uh what's next i'm uh
i'm planning to uh well maybe uh fly
around the world in an electric aircraft
break the world record
of the first electric aircraft uh but
still got a way to go the technology for
that uh
so uh yeah i'm just aiming for the
future
[Music]
i'm coming from a family of fishermen
actually my family have been fishermen
for five generations
[Music]
the fishermen cut these past by accident
so we give them the motivation
and the system to bring it back to the
land we have collected already more than
110 000 kilos of plastic from the bottom
of the sea
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
sunshine will develop widely this
afternoon and it'll be warm for most
places too however island and northern
ireland may take a while to brighten up
and the east of norfolk and suffolk as
well as the hebrides will
probably stay cloudy and cool all day
pollen levels will be high or very high
for most places today but moderate
across the north of scotland
we are currently in the peak of the
grass and spore season
and weed pollen is at a medium risk
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
i know wales will open up covered
restrictions further on saturday despite
increasing numbers of cases across the
country it says that high vaccination
rates mean
hospital admissions remain low so it is
safe
to go down to level one joined now by
the economy minister for wales bond
getting minister
good to see you this morning thanks for
being with us no problem now good to see
you too
just explain exactly what is going to be
happening this weekend
and of course an awful lot of eyes in
wales will be on that date in august on
which
you could see the country moving at to
level zero
okay so from this saturday we're going
to have a number of changes come in to
move to our fully to our
level one that means that six people can
meet up indoors in private homes and
holiday accommodation
it means that organized indoor events
can take place up to a thousand seated
and 200 standing
and our last and our two ice rinks can
reopen as well although one of them is
still being used as a vaccination center
it also means children in groups up to
30 are going to be able to visit
children's residential centers together
there is though still a specific
requirement uh to have the covered risk
assessment
and we still got indoor social
distancing
until the 7th of august that's when we
see a more significant change
uh being made where they're moving to
part of alert level zero with outdoor
events uh not having a particular limit
on those as well so it's a significant
step forward and that is because
whilst our case rates are high there are
140 100 000
lowest in the uk but lower but still
actually quite high and you'll recall
that it wouldn't have been that long ago
case rates of that number we've been
going in reverse
we're not doing that because we've been
really successful in rolling out our
vaccination program
that means that double dose people are
much more protected
and we're not seeing the same level of
harm come into our nhs we've got
73 of adults in wales having had both
doses and that's why
we're looking forward to the 7th of
august when we can release most of the
remaining restrictions and that's when
nightclubs will be open here in wales
for example what we are doing though is
we're keeping the requirements for
face coverings to be worn in most public
indoor
settings we think that's the right
balance both to prevent the potential
spread
of the virus but also to give people
some confidence we've got lots of
clinically vulnerable people who are
concerned about the pace of movement now
and whether they'll still be protected
and able to enjoy the same freedoms as
well
what needs to happen and did what needs
not to happen between now and august the
seventh at four wells to move to alert
level zero i know that you haven't
described the pro
the process the progress towards that
data is irreversible
no because we've always been cautious
and not wanting to give false hope and
the the idea of absolutes through the
covered pandemic is not something that i
think has been
has actually lasted more than a few
weeks so we've always got to look at the
public health position that's both about
case rates
and harm coming into our nhs and also if
there's a new variant of concern
circulating as well
because that on a regular point in time
has changed our approach to the pandemic
and how we keep well safe
in wales most people have done a really
good job at all pulling together to keep
whales safe we think that'll continue
uh the measures we're taking on face
coverings for example it's a different
set of
measures being taken to england so
there's a need to make sure that people
understand the rules for the country
they're in
if people are traveling in the uk but
have seen your own piece of course where
there are businesses in england calling
for that greater clarity so
we think it's a very clear settlement
that people can understand
rules that people can respect it's all
part of us moving together
to try to make sure we don't have to
live with the restrictions we've all had
to
through the first part of the summer and
of course a really really difficult
winter that i certainly don't want to
return to
yep sure i i i do wonder then given
given the different advice
be from the devolver administrations in
in wales and and scotland and that from
boris johnson's government are you
concerned about compliance with
masquerading given that there will be
different situations in different parts
of the united kingdom
well it's an obvious risk and you've
been talking about confusion in england
this morning
we're asking people to understand the
rules for the part of the united kingdom
they're visiting or taking
undertaking business in we want people
to have a great summer visiting in wales
but to respect the rules are in force
here as well
and actually from the point of view of
the businesses that are going to need to
enforce those rules
i think it's much easier to give the
clarity and the simplicity that these
are rules
it's not a choice that they're opting in
or opting out of there's a requirement
a face going to be worn in a variety of
settings i hope that
cloud will make it easier to avoid the
confusion that might otherwise exist but
also for people to do the right thing
the last moment is people are arguing
about whether they need to wear a face
covering in a shop
sorry sorry to interrupt minister but
does does that mean will there be an end
will there
come a point at which uh the welsh
administration
gives people in wales the responsibility
for making these decisions themselves
well there may be a point in time but
it's not going to take place this summer
because we think that the clarity in the
settlement that we've reached for indoor
public spaces is the right balance of
risk
moving forward we're not on a zero risk
position now even with the high levels
of vaccination with an expectation
about the 7th of august 85 percent of
adults would have had both vaccines
it's about the balance in those risks as
ever the settlement we've reached means
there'll be more economic activity
taking place
more freedoms for people to enjoy and to
enjoy responsibly
and if we all keep on doing the right
thing then we can look forward to
further freedoms and actually not going
backwards
to the position we've had to live
through earlier on this year
but i just don't think it's helpful to
try to forecast a point in time at which
we may not need to wear face coverings
we're really looking to get to the end
of this pandemic and to see a recovery
undertaken that isn't going to be set
back if we need to reimpose restrictions
in the future
von gething thanks very much for being
with us no problem
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning welcome to summer finally
summer weather is here with us for the
rest of this week for
most places it is going to be fine dry
sunny and increasingly warm in fact
today since woven's day and if you
believe in the folklore that means
whatever the weather today
is going to be sticking around for the
next 40 days so that makes my job easy
this is the forecast for the next 40
days
we start off with mostly fine conditions
this morning it's bright it's mild but
it's quite cloudy across northern and
western parts but most of the low cloud
mist and fog will
lift and clear good spells of sunshine a
very warm day but
cooler and cloudier around the eastern
coastal areas and across the far
northwest as well
it will be cloudy with some light rain
or drizzle
the weather sponsored by qatar airways